un plaisir de recevoir Madame Michel
Ramiz directrice des Amériques et des
Caraïbes au ministère de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères merci Madame d'avoir
accepté la proposition de cette audition
vous le savez nous avons eu l'occasion
d'en parler encore récemment notre
commission considère l'Amérique latine
comme un sujet tout à fait prioritaire
plusieurs missions se sont ainsi déjà
rendues dans cette zone au cours des
dernières années en Colombie en avril
2019 en Guyane je dirigeais moi-même la
délégation en décembre 2020 et dans
quelques semaines cinq sénateurs de
notre commission vont se rendre au
Brésil en Guyane et au Guyana
dans cette perspective nous avons donc
souhaité vous entendre pour que vous
puissiez nous faire une présentation
générale de la situation économique
politique et sociale du Brésil alors que
vient de débuter la nouvelle présidente
Lula bien sûr il sera aussi utile que
vous nous présentiez l'état de la
relation bilatérale avec ce pays qu'il
s'agisse du partenariat stratégique qui
a été conclu en 2006 ou encore
de la coopération transfrontalière car
nous ne perdons pas de vue que ce ce
pays partage c'est combien 1000
700 plus de 700 km de frontière commune
avec la Guyane
vous nous direz en particulier quelles
sont les perspectives de relance des
relations franco-brésiliennes après une
présidence de Monsieur bolsonaro qui
avait été marqué par une défiance
réciproque la visite de la ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères en
février dernier constituant à cet égard
un signal important
merci aussi de nous tracer quelques
perspectives et en jeu auxquels est
confronté le Guyana ce pays qui est
encore pauvre et parfois présenté comme
un futur cathare du fait de ces
importantes réserves pétrolières selon
la Banque mondiale sa production de
pétrole devrait quasiment cadre rupler
entre 21 entre 2021 et 2024 et toujours
selon les projections du FMI le Pays-Bas
le PIB guyaneien par habitant en parité
de pouvoir d'achat pourraient se situer
juste devant celui de la Suisse qui nous
interroge évidemment vous nous direz
aussi si les politiques mises en oeuvre
par le gouvernement guyanien vous semble
de nature à favoriser le développement
de ce pays et éviter la mise en place
d'une économie reposant uniquement sur
la rente pétrolière laquelle pose à bien
d'autres égards protections de
l'environnement bien des questions
vous nous présenterez aussi les
perspectives de renforcement de nos
relations diplomatiques et commerciales
avec ce pays lors de son discours
d'investiture le président Lula a
souhaité donner un nouvel élan à
l'intégration régionale en Amérique du
Sud vous nous indiquerez si une relance
du merco sourd voire de Luna source
l'Union des nations sud-américaine vous
semble crédible dans les mois ou années
à venir et qu'elle pourrait en être les
contours et bien sûr vous pourrez
revenir sur la manière dont un éventuel
retour du leadership brésilien est perçu
par ses voisins enfin nous souhaiterions
que vous nous précisiez comment la
France entend se positionner dans cette
zone dans quelle mesure la présidente
espagnole de l'Union européenne au
second semestre 2023 pourrait constituer
une opportunité pour l'Union européenne
d'approfondir ses relations avec
l'Amérique latine et nous présenter les
attentes françaises vis-à-vis du sommet
UE c'est l'axe c'est-à-dire la
Communauté des États latinos américains
et Caraïbes sommet qui est prévu en
juillet
23 en d'autres termes je crois qu'il y a
beaucoup d'interrogations qui pèsent sur
l'avenir de ce continent sud-américain
sur la relation que la France et du
meilleur général l'Europe ont avec ces
pays
lorsque nous rencontrons les
ambassadeurs d'Américains ce que j'ai
fait encore récemment il se plaignent
d'une forme quelque part de désintérêt
enfin vous connaissez bien leur le Light
motif qui revient régulièrement peu de
visites ministérielle pas de visite
présidentielle ou trop rare alors même
que le chancelier Scholl ça fait une
tournée de plusieurs jours dans tout ce
continent donc là aussi alors que nous
sommes nous physiquement présents à
travers la Guyane
il est intéressant de voir ce que l'on
ce que l'on peut développer comme
coopération Madame la Directrice comme
nous en avons l'habitude je vais vous
donner la parole pour un propos
liminaire et puis après donc on aura un
jeu de
questions-réponses je rappelle que cette
audition est captée elle est diffusée
sur le site internet du Sénat et je vous
donne donc la parole
infiniment monsieur le Président alors
monsieur le Président Cambon Mesdames et
Messieurs les mesdames les sénatrices et
messieurs les sénateurs merci beaucoup
de m'avoir invité à donc vous faire une
présentation sur le Brésil devant la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées du Sénat
c'est un grand plaisir pour moi d'être
ici avec le sous-directeur d'Amérique du
Sud monsieur Jean-Christophe Talard
fleuri
j'ai bien noté que votre commission ou
une partie de celle-ci se rendra au
Brésil du 9 au 17 avril
il y a effectivement une relance de la
relation avec ce pays non seulement au
niveau du gouvernemental mais aussi au
niveau parlementaire avec de nombreuses
missions et celle-ci tout à fait au
Portugal et nous avons pris connaissance
de votre projet de programme
donc voilà on va essayer de vous
éclairer le maximum avant cette visite
je voudrais peut-être faire une petite
assise sur les relations entre la France
et l'Amérique latine que vous avez
évoquée monsieur le Président bien
évidemment nous entendons ces attentes
de la part des pays latinaméricains de
plus de visites de plus d'échanges
je dois dire que depuis que j'ai pris
mes fonctions j'essaie de corriger non
seulement cette tendance mais aussi une
certaine perception
l'Amérique latine est importante pour la
France même si durant le premier
quinquennat du président Macron il n'y a
pas pu avoir de visite mais nous savons
que ce quinquennat a quand même été
marqué par des crises historiques le
covid les gilets jaunes et autres crises
qui ont bousculé l'agenda international
le président de la République souhaite
faire une une visite en Amérique latine
cette année et je souligne quand même
qu'il reçoit beaucoup les chefs d'État
étrangers ça ne se voit peut-être pas
mais il a reçu plusieurs de ces
homologues d'Amérique latine encore
récemment vendredi le président du Costa
Rica il a reçu le président d'Argentine
plusieurs fois il a reçu le président
Lula en novembre avant qu'il ne soit élu
le président Petro de Colombie donc
c'est visites sont aussi font aussi
partie de l'agenda politique
entre nos deux continents
le Brésil c'est un géant c'est 8
millions cinq kilomètres carrés donc
c'est 15 fois la France c'est 212
millions d'habitants
c'est un partenaire historique de la
France avec lequel nous avons un
partenaire stratégique depuis 2008 il
avait été signé en 2006 par les
présidents Chirac et Lula et a donné
lieu à établissement d'un d'une feuille
de route entre les présidents Lula et
Sarkozy en 2008
c'est un pays avec lequel comme vous
l'avez dit la relation a été
[Musique]
distendu pendant le mandat du président
précédent mais que nous relançons
car nous y avons avec ce pays de
nombreux enjeux de nombreux sujets
d'intérêt alors
peut-être rappeler que comme vous l'avez
dit monsieur le Président la ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
Catherine Colonna s'est rendu en visite
officielle du 8 au 9 avril pardon dans
ce pays afin de relancer la relation
avec le Brésil il y a trouvé un pays
toujours polarisé avec une partie de la
population qui n'a toujours pas reconnu
reconnu une manière psychologique
l'élection du président Lula et
s'exprime sur les réseaux sociaux nous
avons vu ce qui s'est passé le 8 janvier
une semaine après l'investiture du
président Lula avec l'assaut contre les
institutions brésiliennes
Parlement gouvernement Cour suprême qui
ont montré qu'une partie de la
population
est encore voilà n'a pas intégré cette
alternance et peut-être manipuler par
des par des réseaux sociaux
les les quatre années qui viennent de
s'écouler
n'ont pas permis de développer un agenda
politique de haut niveau mais elles
n'ont pas empêché la poursuite de nos
relations économiques et culturelles
donc nous ne sommes pas nous n'avons pas
interrompu nos relations avec le Brésil
nous avons également beaucoup travaillé
avec les États fédérés avec les mairies
le Président
nous y avons de multiples interlocuteurs
la politique intérieure brésilienne vous
le savez Lula a été élu avec une marge
de 5 de 9% puisqu'il a été lu avec 5,9%
de voix contre 49,1% pour son concurrent
il a pris ses fonctions le 1er janvier
et il sait qu'il doit devoir rassembler
sa population il a nommé un gouvernement
qui qui très large c'est à dire que ça
n'est pas seulement le Parti des
Travailleurs c'est un gouvernement qui
va largement rassembler au centre afin
de couvrir un certain nombre de
sensibilité
sachant que Le président Lula doit
composer avec un congrès conservateur et
donc ceci peut constituer une difficulté
pour mettre en oeuvre son programme et
il doit faire preuve de sa capacité à
concilier les inconciliales et notamment
un tiers de lectorat qui nous reconnaît
toujours pas sa victoire comme l'a
montré le
montrer les événements du 8 janvier
je j'avais accompagné la ministre au
Brésil en février et le sentiment que
nous avions c'est que Lula se sentait
finalement renforcé par ces événements
du 8 janvier qui avait pu être maîtrisé
et qui avait heureusement n'avait pas
dégénéré en situation incontrôlable
parce qu'il a réussi à obtenir une
expression des deux présidents des deux
chambres et des gouverneurs pour
défendre la démocratie donc au Brésil on
considère que la façon dont cette crise
a été surmontée
renforce la légitimité du président Lula
ce qu'on voit aussi c'est qu'il a été
servi par un pouvoir judiciaire qui a
défendu fermement les institutions
démocratiques puisque la Cour suprême a
été prononcé pour l'ordre
constitutionnel donc le la bénéficie
d'une dynamique en sa faveur
toutefois il devra rapidement engranger
des succès
et la seule dynamique économique qu'il
avait emporté lors de ces deux premiers
mandats ne suffira sans doute pas face
aux immenses besoin du Brésil ou plus de
30 millions de personnes souffrent
encore de la femme donc la lutte contre
la faim c'est un de ces chantiers
prioritaire
le pays le Brésil c'est la 9e économie
mondiale mais il a une économie
comment dire à structure essentiellement
ces exportations sont des exploitations
de produits primaires
produits agricoles minerais pétrole et
une productivité qui mérite d'être
améliorée et c'est un pays qui importe
des produits manufacturés donc un grand
émergent qui doit faire évoluer son
économie
un pays continent et
qui affronte évidemment des défis on
sait que l'économie brésilienne a
souffert du des conséquences du covid
vous rappeler que le covid a fait 700
000 décès au Brésil avec une politique
sanitaire
une politique sanitaire qui a pu être
contestable donc il se remet de cette
période
délicate de son histoire
alors en matière de politique étrangère
bien sûr le retour de Lula au Brésil a
été célébré dans toutes les régions du
monde aussi bien dans la région que à
l'extérieur parce que Lola est vu comme
celui qui peut être une voix qui porte
dans ce qu'on appelle le sud global mais
également peu
relancer les processus d'intégration
régionale qui ont été mis à mal pendant
les dernières années du fait des
divisions en Amérique latines les crises
américaines d'Amérique latine et
notamment la crise vénézuélienne
entraîné une polarisation du continent
entre ceux qui estimaient qu'il fallait
avoir une politique de pression maximale
sur le Venezuela et donc rompu la
relation avec ce pays et ceux qui
étaient plus dans une approche flexible
du fait de l'élection du la mais aussi
de l'arrivée au pouvoir de gouvernement
de gauche sur ce continent la Colombie
le Honduras aussi le Brésil on assiste à
des réconciliations et
cette c'est ces alternances ont permis
de comment dire de réconcilier continent
notamment au sein d'organisation
régionale comme la sélac donc la
Communauté des États d'Amérique latine
et de retrouver un dialogue
intra-américain et d'ailleurs
intra-européen puisque nous aurons un
sommet Union européenne c'est là au mois
de juillet
la voie du Brésil sera très attendue sur
les enjeux environnementaux nous savons
que c'est ce qui a manqué dans le Brésil
précédent
Lula a d'emblée à qu'il donnerait
la priorité au sujet environnementaux
comme vous le savez il s'est déplacé à
la cop27 et annoncé qu'il accueillera la
COP 30 en 2025 en Amazonie
il entend aussi être une voix qui porte
comme un pont entre le Nord et le Sud et
également à investir la coopération Sud
donc c'est un loup là qui occupera son
comment dire son espace et qui est très
attendu pour autant
le Brésil de 2023 ne s'éloignera pas des
fondamentaux du passé c'est un pays
culturellement
occidental mais qui se refuse à
l'alignement sur l'Europe où les
États-Unis
nous le voyons bien il est critique des
interventions militaires des sanctions
c'est un fervent défenseur du droit
international
nous le voyons dans le dans le conflit
en Ukraine c'est un pays qui comment
dirais-je à voter les résolutions des
Nations Unies tout en exprimant voilà
des positions
cherchant une sorte de neutralité entre
les deux belligérants et donc ce n'est
pas un pays qui sera comment dirais-je
qui ne souhaiteraient s'aligner sur un
sur un camp ou sur un autre
sur les questions économiques
sa politique sera dictée par les
intérêts commerciaux du pays nous savons
que la Chine constitue enfin le débouché
chinois constitué un tiers de ces
exportations donc c'est une donnée
importante nous savons aussi que le
Brésil est dépendant d'importation russe
notamment les engrais donc ceci peut
expliquer certaines prises de position
concernant le les rapports avec l'Union
européenne donc nous aurons au mois de
juillet
c'est ce sommet Union européenne c'est
lac qui est une retour de cet enceinte
après 7 ans voire 8 ans d'interruption
le les Européens n'ont pas pu recevoir
dans leur globalité en raison des
divisions au sein de ces pays d'Amérique
latine puisque on ne pouvait pas réunir
en même temps certains états et surtout
parce que le Brésil s'était retiré de la
sélac à cause de la crise de
vénézuélienne donc on n'avait pas assez
lac au complet celui-ci sera de nouveau
au complet en juillet à Bruxelles ce que
nous en attendons c'est déjà une
réactivation du dialogue sur les
questions
économiques bien sûr sur les questions
environnementales sur les questions
énergétiques et sur les questions de
démocratie car si nous avons à la table
l'intégralité des pays sud-américains et
latines américain c'est aussi pour que
nous puissions aborder de manière
franche les crises
les questions d'État de droit qui dans
certains pays sont mis à mal et que nous
puissions avoir un dialogue franc sur
les attentes des uns et des autres et
sur l'évolution de ce continent qui vu
de loin et dans sa globalité et celui
qui partage des valeurs démocratiques de
la France et qui partagent les principes
des tas de droit mais qui en certains
points du globe de cette région lative
américaine connaît des crises qui sont
préoccupantes notamment en matière de
droits de l'homme et des tas de droit
concernant le Mercosur le Mercosur donc
on prend quatre pays le Brésil
l'Argentine le Paraguay Uruguay qui ne
se positionne pas nécessairement
toujours de la même manière d'autant que
vous nous avons dans ce groupe de pays
conservateurs deux pays progressistes
donc on le voit bien dans les
discussions sur le la conclusion de
l'accord
uomer kosour il y a pas une animalité de
du côté du Mercosur non plus donc c'est
un sujet qui sera vu avec intérêt nous
savons que la présidente espagnole comme
vous l'avez mentionné monsieur le
président souhaite utiliser le sommeil
pour une relance de la relation avec
l'Amérique latine
nous y sommes tout à fait favorables
mais il y a des choses qui ne pourront
pas forcément se faire dès le mois de
juillet parce que il faut aussi l'accord
des deux des deux blocs de région
la relation bilatérale comme je vous
l'ai dit les pendant cette 4 ans de
mandats de gérer bolsonaro il n'y a eu
des visites bilatérales tout début du
mandat puisque Jean-Yves Le Drian y est
allé en 2019 mais à partir 2019 nous
avons connu une crise liée à des
divergences sur la question
d'environnement et les sujets amazoniens
tout a commencé vous savez avec les
incendies en Amazonie en 2019 qui ont
qui ont aggravé la déforestation il y a
eu ensuite des incidents bilatéraux et
donc il n'y a pas eu de visite
bilatérale pendant ces quatre années les
contacts entre-aux fonctionnaires se
sont poursuivis
et les contacts techniques se sont
poursuivis parce que c'était important
nous avons également des relations avec
les États notamment l'état de San Paolo
mais le dialogue politique de niveau n'a
pu reprendre qu'au début de l'année donc
avec la ministre la visite de la
ministre Catherine Colonna au Brésil
donc reçu par le par son homologue
maroviéra
la ministre a également été reçu à Sao
Paulo par le par le gouverneur
elle a eu des contacts avec
l'Organisation du traité de coopération
amazonienne qui est une organisation qui
rassemble tous les états amazoniens mais
qui était également un peu en pause du
fait de l'absence de leadership des pays
qui la composent
nous avons annoncé que nous allions
signer une feuille de route pour
actualiser notre partenaire stratégique
mais bilatérale bon qui date de 2008 qui
doit être relancé qui doit être nourri
les sujets d'intérêt dans la relation
francophone brésilienne ils sont bien
sûr bilatéraux ils sont tous domaines de
la défense de la culture il touche des
questions de langue française
il touche ces questions de
désinformation aussi de lutte contre la
désinformation mais ils doivent aussi
inclure les questions globales
c'est-à-dire la lutte contre le
changement climatique les questions de
santé les questions d'alimentation et
puis la gouvernance mondiale en général
vous savez que le Président de la
République réunira les 22 23 juin un
sommet à Paris pour
reformer
restructuré réformer l'architecture
financière internationale le Brésil y a
été invité donc le Brésil est un grand
acteur dont nous attendons la
participation dans toutes ces enceintes
s'agissant de l'Ukraine comme je l'ai
dit c'est un acteur majeur du dialogue
Nord-Sud le Brésil a voté en faveur de
la résolution qui condamnait l'invasion
russe il s'est entretenu avec le
président zellinski il a défendu
l'intégral l'intégrité territoriale de
l'Ukraine ainsi qu'une solution
pacifique à l'invasion donc nous avons
un dialogue avec le Brésil sur ces
questions je rappelle que le Brésil est
membre des BRICS
nous plaidons également pour le
renforcement et le rééquilibrage de nos
relations économiques bilatérales notre
commerce et bilatéral s'est amélioré
depuis le début de l'année comme je l'ai
dit la ministre s'est rendu dans l'état
de Sao Paulo qui représente à peu près
un tiers du PIB brésilien
et elle a reçu la Communauté française
des affaires qui est nombreuse dans cet
état qui notamment peut
constituer si vous voulez un pont pour
travailler sur les questions de
transition écologique transition
énergétique nous avons à peu près toutes
les entreprises françaises dans ce
domaine qui sont implantés à Sao Paulo
en termes d'agenda politique nous aurons
et votre visite en fait partie un agenda
très riche de déplacement au Brésil donc
votre commission le groupe d'amitié de
France Brésil de l'Assemblée nationale
devra y aller aussi la secrétaire
général du ministère fera des
consultations bilatérales au mois
d'avril juste après votre venue il est
probable que le ministre délégué au
Commerce extérieur fera également une
visite nous recevrons le gouverneur de
l'état de San Paolo vendredi
donc vous voyez c'est un agenda très
riche qui se dessine
et nous serons en profiter pour si vous
voulez relancer tous les secteurs qui
méritent de l'être
imaginez de nouvelles coopérations y
compris avec les états
et comme vous le savez enfin le Brésil
est a été invité à rejoindre le cede
donc organisation de coopération et de
développement économique
comme deux autres pays d'Amérique latine
le Pérou et l'Argentine et donc nous
avons proposé de l'aider dans cette
adhésion qui qui suppose des
négociations assez longues et qui
exigent que ces pays futurs adhérents
remplissent des normes en matière
d'environnement et nous savons qu'avec
le président Lula ce sera
probablement le cas
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire sur le
Brésil bien sûr je serai heureuse de
répondre à vos questions s'il y en a
peut-être je passe à Rihanna tout de
suite ou vous voulez qu'on fasse une
pause
d'accord
j'ai oublié quelque chose qui est
important monsieur le Président je sais
que votre commission se rendra dans
l'état d'alamata donc il est à du Nord
Est qui fait la frontière avec la Guyane
française et donc nous souhaitons bien
sûr la relation transfrontalière est
extrêmement importante et nous réunirons
pour la première fois depuis quatre ans
c'est ça la commission mixte Franco Guy
enfin franco-brésilienne pour la Guyane
à Cayenne début juillet pour examiner
tous les sujets transfrontaliers
c'est-à-dire le pont entre nos deux pays
les questions de sécurité les questions
de lutte contre les trafics les
questions de circulation des personnes
donc cette cette coopération qui avait
été un peu mise en pause va également
reprendre dès le mois de juillet avec
cette grande commission que je
présiderais avec le préfet de Guyane
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire en
introduction merci merci
ce sera d'autant plus important que moi
je retire de du déplacement des avions
fait en Guyane le fait que la frontière
est très poreuse enfin les gens passent
d'un côté l'autre du fleuve exactement
comment changerait de trottoir donc
c'est un peu c'est pas aussi facile
alors dans les questions
alors André Vallini
merci monsieur le Président j'ai la
chance de faire partie de la délégation
qui va bientôt
partir en Amérique du Sud Brésil Guyana
et Suriname on multiplie les auditions
c'est un travail très sérieux c'est pas
du tourisme que l'on va faire mais vous
savez bien puisque vous participez tous
et toutes à des missions comme ça on a
beaucoup de d'auditions là chaque
semaine depuis deux semaines on va
continuer jusqu'à la semaine prochaine
et notamment en vue de notre
participation enfin notre visite du
salon de l'armement qui va se tenir à
Rio le Brésil achète des hélicoptères on
construit des sous-marins ensemble ils
envisager lesquels en César etc etc et
en même temps on nous explique que le
Brésil n'a aucun problème avec ses
voisins aucun problème frontalier c'est
peut-être le seul pays d'Amérique du Sud
qui n'a aucun problème frontalier avec
quelques voisins que ce soit donc je
m'interroge je vous interroge la
directrice sur la raison pour laquelle
le président Lula après bolzonaro
d'ailleurs dans la suite de bolzanaro
veut à ce point réarmer entre guillemets
son pays d'autant qu'on nous explique
que les Brésiliens souhaitent
renforcer leur armement et comment dire
moins utiliser les forces armées en
interne pour les rediriger si j'ose dire
sur l'extérieur alors qu'ils n'ont pas
d'ennemis a priori et pas de problème
merci André gatelin
oui merci monsieur le Président ma
question est un tout petit peu à la
marge du Brésil mais le concert
il y a 4 ans la crise vénézuélienne a
provoqué
l'immigration le départ en exil de
d'environ 5 millions de venez nigériens
après
10% de sa population
nombreux sont ceux d'ailleurs qui se
sont rendus au Brésil qui leur accordent
je crois des visas parce que il est très
difficile d'obtenir sans gros moyens
financiers un passeport pour quitter le
Venezuela comment voyez-vous l'impact de
cette situation qui perdure sur la
région surtout que des élections
on ne sait pas si elles seront libres et
non faussées devraient avoir lieu
l'année prochaine je vous remercie
merci Jacques le nez
Madame la Directrice
je voudrais moi vous demander comment se
déroule la coopération avec les pays
frontaliers et plus précisément le
Brésil
par rapport à la Guyane française et
notamment dans la lutte contre les
trafics stupéfiants paillage mais aussi
pêche clandestine et je tiens bien sûr à
rendre hommage au maréchal de logis chef
arnouland qui est décédé le week-end
dernier dans la lutte contre leur
paillage et une question un peu
différente mais je voudrais savoir quel
lien existe entre les pays d'Amérique
latine et la Russie vous l'avez un peu
évoqué mais également la Chine
il faut
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Directrice je ferais parti aussi de
la délégation qui aura l'honneur de se
rendre avec le président valini
donc en Brésil dans quelques dans
quelques semaines et dans ce cadre là je
voudrais juste vous poser une question
un peu dans le droit fil de celle que
qui viennent d'être posée
par rapport aux relations
franco-brésilienne autour de la Guyane
vous venez de nous dire de nous donner
une information importante c'est qu'il y
a la commission mixte qui va se réunir
au mois de juillet et en fait comment
pourrions-nous agir pour faire de telle
et sortes que nous puissions aider à la
préparation par le biais de notre visite
à Macapa mais aussi à Cayenne donc faire
avancer les choses parce que comme cela
vient d'être dit par notre collègue
Launay la situation est une situation je
veux dire difficile par rapport à leur
paillage clandestins par rapport aux
migration mais aussi par rapport à la
pêche illégale et je me rappelle dans le
cadre de notre rapport que que j'avais
fait avec la délégation des Outre-mer de
témoignages de pêcheurs guyanais au
regard d'acte hostile de la part de
pêcheurs clandestins
donc brésilien qui s'apparentait une
forme de piraterie c'est à dire ils
étaient menacés avec des armes et donc
par rapport à cela que pouvons-nous
faire pour faire de telle sorte que la
souveraineté de notre pays tendent sur
un plan terrestre que maritime puisse
être respecté au regard donc de ces
éléments pour lesquels je veux dire on
peut suspecter les autorités
brésiliennes n'ont pas de les organiser
mais en tout état de cause peut-être de
faire preuve d'une certaine complaisance
en la matière et donc que pensez-vous de
cela et qu'est-ce qui pourrait être fait
ne serait-ce qu'un autre niveau pour
faire passer un certain nombre de
messages très fort
merci Olivier Cadic merci monsieur le
Président Madame ambassadrice oui moi je
ne ferai pas partie de la mission par
contre il se trouve que j'irai dans
l'état du Parana prochainement lors de
la fin du mois d'avril et donc j'irai à
kouritiba des cours et une ville fameuse
puis puisque c'est là que le procureur
Sergio Moreau donc avait mené l'enquête
sur les histoires le blanchiment qui
avait abouti un inoccupation et un
emprisonnement du président Lula la
semaine dernière le président Lula a eu
des mots très injurieux à l'égard de
celui qui est devenu aujourd'hui
sénateur Sergio Moreau les médias
brésiliens en parlent tous évidemment le
sénateur a répondu sur CNN on sent bien
que vous l'avez rappelé dès le début du
fait qu'il y avait une polarisation
toujours existante au Brésil simplement
vous savez que les milieux économiques
ne sont pas les plus grands supporters
du président Lula au Brésil et donc
comment appréciez-vous la relation
économique avec
ce pays est-ce que vous aurez une je
dirais des discussions équilibrées aussi
bien avec l'opposition puisque vous
savez que au Parlement elle est pas
forcément favorable au président Lula
merci merci Guillaume Gontard
merci Monsieur le monsieur le Président
Madame l'ambassadrice et j'avais une
question sur une des premières mesures
du président Lula en janvier a été la
création d'un ministère des peuples
autochtones et donc je voulais savoir
c'est vrai que c'est un sujet sur lequel
on a travaillé notamment dans le texte
sur le l'aide au développement puisqu'on
a fait rentrer justement la
reconnaissance de ces peuples
autochtones et je voulais du coup savoir
si à travers ce ministère et je crois
que c'est que Sonia Agora qui qui est en
charge ou on en est sur les avancées en
tout cas les mesures qui peuvent être
prises sur la protection des peuples
autochtones et qui ont été évidemment
beaucoup touchés par la question de la
déforestation et savoir où en est la
situation de ces peuples autochtones
merci merci Yannick vogrenard pour
terminer merci monsieur le président
j'aurais posé une question par rapport
aux positionnement du Brésil et parfois
d'autres pays d'Amérique latine sur le
conflit en Ukraine et sous l'agression
russe et l'abstention du Brésil à l'ONU
vous nous avez dit que ça pouvait se
justifier par le fait en partie par le
fait que le Brésil était fortement
important d'engrais en provenance de
Russie il va y avoir un sommet européen
également avec le Brésil en juillet
comme on l'Europe est susceptible
d'intervenir sur le plan économique en
particulier pour tenter d'un fléchir la
position brésilienne sur le conflit
ukrainien et voir d'autres pays
d'Amérique latine
merci
la directrice premier train de question
auquel vous pouvez répondre
bah écoutez nous avons après nous avons
dans 50 minutes une seconde audition
donc
si on veut parler un peu de Viana
vous pouvez rassembler les questions
s'il y a des thématiques qui se
recoupent
bon alors d'accord donc je vais
commencer par la question de la défense
effectivement
vous l'avez dit on a nous avons un
partenariat en matière de défense qui
suppose une coopération
qui suppose une coopération entre nos
deux pays pour des questions donc de
sous-marin vous savez que la France a
construit le programme de sous-marin
brésilien ainsi que le programme
d'hélicoptère il y a une usine délivrace
qui
opère au Brésil
pourquoi pourquoi le Brésil se doit-il
de ces projets c'est parce que tout
grand pays a besoin d'une armée dotée
bien sûr il n'y a pas de menace contre
le Brésil actuellement mais on verrait
mal un pays
totalement démuni de force de force
armées nous espérons d'ailleurs que le
Brésil d'investira davantage les
opérations de maintien de la paix qu'il
ne l'a fait jusqu'à maintenant
l'armée est une institution qui compte
au Brésil qui est loyal mais qui compte
et qui a besoin d'équipements et et pour
sa stature régionale je pense que le
Brésil ne peut pas se permettre de ne
pas avoir d'équipement
moderne
et une armée
équipée donc ce n'est pas dans un but
belliciste pardon
on est prisonniers d'une espèce de
préjugé globale qui qui veut qu'un pays
soit forcément armé jusqu'aux dents même
s'il n'y a aucune menace à ses portes
enfin c'est je veux pas jouer le
pacifiste de service mais c'est quand
même curieux comme réponse
c'est aussi pour dissuader les éventuels
les éventuels agresseurs tous les tous
les pays du monde se dotent
leurs armées d'équipements afin de
pouvoir réagir au cas où parfois la
menace c'est une surprise il n'y en a
pas actuellement sur le Brésil je pense
que c'est un grand pays un grand pays
qui souhaite se doter d'une force de
réaction sérieuse
alors oui l'autre l'autre
[Musique]
la confiance que le Brésil manifeste aux
industries de défense française
notamment pour ses sous-marins et quand
même très important parce que quand on
regarde la quantité de l'espace maritime
qu'il convient quand même de contrôler
même si il n'y a pas de contentieux ou
de d'intention belliqueuse mais enfin
moi quand je vois ces ambassadeurs là
ils me font ils ne font pas de leur
grande inquiétude y compris jusqu'à
l'Atlantique à l'Atlantique Sud enfin
l'armée est aussi là pour lutter contre
les menaces intérieures ou ou maritime
les trafics j'allais le dire donc à la
fois par exemple la lutte contre la
déforestation et les menée par l'armée
la lutte contre leur paillage le
contrôle des frontières parce que les
frontières vous savez que l'Amérique
latine est un pays de de transit et de
production de produits stupéfiants donc
il faut aussi avoir des équipements qui
permettent de contrôler ses eaux et
l'usage illicite de ses oies des fins de
trafic donc ce n'est pas seulement dans
une dans un une confrontation avec un
état mais ça peut être avec des groupes
qui qui qui pratiquent des activités de
trafic donc la deuxième question
concernée la crise vénézuélienne oui
donc la crise Venezuela monsieur le
sénateur effectivement a mis sur les
routes 7 millions de Vénézuéliens donc
soit 20% en fait c'est un petit peu plus
20% parce que ça augmentait de la
population vénézuélienne et à migré dans
les pays voisins bien sûr au Brésil mais
en Colombie au Chili et dans la région
je dirais que cette crise
multidimensionnelle dure depuis ça fait
une dizaine d'années que la crise est
approfondie au Venezuela
nous nous essayons de contribuer à la
résolution de la crise et nous espérons
que le Brésil nouvellement dirigé par
Lula sera également une voie qui va
inciter Maduro à aller des élections
libres et démocratiques en 2024 on n'y
est pas encore
nous savons qu'il y a un chemin de
négociation entre l'opposition et le
régime qui avait démarré d'ailleurs peu
après que le Président de la République
est reçu les deux chefs négociateurs au
Forum de Paris ce processus est à
nouveau suspendu nous nous agissons sur
tous les acteurs pour qu'ils reprennent
la proximité enfin la relative proximité
des élections américaines n'est pas pour
rien dans la difficulté de ce dossier
parce que vous savez que tout ce qui
concerne le Venezuela est très suivi par
le congrat américain notamment tous les
les démocrates et les républicains
d'origine latine américaine en Floride
donc c'est une crise profonde qui nous
suivons de très près et nous demandons
au Brésil d'être aussi une voix qui qui
va permettre une issue pacifique bon
concernant le l'immigration les États
voisins si vous voulez en essayer de
donner un statut à ces migrants les
Colombiens l'ont fait
les Brésiliens l'ont fait afin que ces
migrants ne soient pas dénués de
sécurité sociale le droit à la santé
voir de droit au travail mais c'est sûr
que tant que la crise Venezuela ne sera
pas résolue en assistera à une la
poursuite de ces migrations massives
la coopération transfrontalière alors je
dois dire que la coopération est
ancienne
la coopération est ancienne
elle se déroule en matière de lutte
contre leur paillage puisque vous savez
que ce sont les la plupart du temps les
employeurs brésiliens qui viennent en
Guyane pour chercher de l'or par des
moyens illicites donc notamment dans les
rivières avec en utilisant le mercure
qui pollue les eaux
elle a été elle peut être améliorée et
le nouveau gouvernement brésilien est
très conscient qu'il faut renforcer
cette coopération transfrontalière alors
nous avons plusieurs instances nous
avons un comité de coopération
policière à la frontière qui est en
train d'être davantage doté par les
Brésiliens
nous nous coopérons
nous avons coopéré d'ailleurs récemment
avec une opération qui a lieu qui a eu
lieu sur le fleuve au ya pop
les autorités brésiliennes sont tout à
fait heureuses que nous réunions
prochainement cette cette commission
afin de renforcer la lutte contre la
pêche clandestine leur paillage
le trafic de sorte de trafic
et
voit cela comme vraiment une question
prioritaire l'état de la MAPA et
lui-même très concerné par si vous
voulez un état qui est dans le nord-est
donc un état moins développé que le sud
et j'ai senti les autorités brésiliennes
très désireuse de délivrer sur ce
terrain la ministre a beaucoup insisté
là-dessus et donc je pense que la
réunion que nous aurons à Cayenne pourra
préparer le terrain évidemment lorsque
vous serez Madame et Monsieur les
sénateurs dessinatrices dans la MAPA
voilà tout ce que vous pourrez faire
pour dire que nous attendons un
renforcement de cette coopération à
l'occasion de cette commission mixte qui
aura lieu donc en Guyana Cayenne début
janvier sera
utile pour nous parce que c'est une
question de crédibilité du Brésil c'est
une question de meilleure coexistence de
deux pays frontaliers
et il faut que les Brésiliens mettent
davantage de moyens
pour
permettre
qui est des interlocuteurs brésiliens de
l'autre côté de la frontière
alors attendez je revois oui les
relations entre la effectivement la
présence chinoise et la présence russe
nous le savons la Chine a fortement
investi le continent
sous une forme qui peut se faire un
petit peu à bas bruit à travers des
investissements nombreux à travers des
financements la Chine voit en Amérique
du Sud un réservoir de ressources
naturelles
donc nous voyons effectivement des les
Chinois remportaient des contrats
d'exploitation de matières premières
mais aussi et de ressources naturelles
mais aussi en matière d'infrastructure
donc nous le savons
c'est un pays avec lequel beaucoup
d'États font une grande partie de leur
commerce extérieurs voilà c'est une
donnée que nous connaissons c'est sûr
que s'il y a plus d'Europe nous pourrons
davantage
comment dire être présent face à cette à
la montée de cette puissance chinoise
mais si vous voulez pour l'instant
elle se traduit par des une forte
présence économique et l'autre sujet
important pour la Chine dans cette
région c'est la question de Taïwan
puisque sur les 14 États qui
reconnaissent encore Taïwan 8 se trouve
en Amérique latine dans les Caraïbes ce
qui est plus de la moitié donc c'est un
enjeu diplomatique sachant que la Chine
chaque fois qu'elle engrange un
basculement entre Taïwan et Pékin en
grand j'ai une victoire diplomatique
voilà alors l'année dernière c'est le
dinkaragua qui a basculé récemment il y
a quelques jours c'est long du race donc
la liste des pays qui reconnaît Taïwan
diminue il y a pour l'instant Guatemala
Bélize Haïti des îles des Caraïbes et le
Paraguay donc pour la pour la Chine
c'est aussi un terrain de confrontation
avec Taïwan et donc elle y met les
moyens et c'est vrai que depuis quelques
années on observe des basculements
réguliers
la Russie est peu présente sur le plan
économique je dois dire que le même
l'influence russe n'est pas
mis présente en Amérique latine
simplement la Russie a de fort alliés
des alliés très fidèles qui sont le
Venezuela et le Nicaragua et bien sûr
Cuba donc nous observons à la fois le
fait que ces pays ont finalement je
parle surtout du Venezuela a résisté à
suresister à la politique de sanctions
mise en œuvre par les États-Unis en
premier lieu et aussi par l'Union
européenne grâce au soutien russe qui
fournissent effectivement appui
militaire
conseiller le Nicaragua c'est la même
chose les garagua et
financé une partie en partie par la
Russie dont nous avons des points de
présence russe sur le continent qui ont
permis à ces états de résister à des
politiques de pression et a finalement
en quelque part pérenniser les crises et
donc ça c'était un souci la pénétration
d'acteurs étrangers dans la région qui
complique un petit peu le règlement des
crises j'essaie d'aller vite
alors pardonnez-moi
les questions économiques ah oui non
oui alors
effectivement le secteur privé
le secteur privé
tout le secteur privé n'est pas
favorable l'arrivée du président Lula et
celui-ci le sait c'est la raison pour
laquelle il a nommé comme vice-président
monsieur akmin qui est d'ailleurs son
ennemi politique qui est un libéral qui
est également ministre de l'Industrie et
du Commerce et qui a su donner des gages
au secteur privé en réalité Lula ne va
pas remettre en cause la primauté de
l'agronégoce au Brésil il en a besoin il
sait que c'est un volet très très
important de son économie et il sait
ménager ces secteurs là et notamment
grâce à Gérald Wagner qui qui est un
petit peu son voilà l'interface avec ces
secteurs
le Brésil souhaite également se
réindustrialiser donc
le président n'a pas du tout l'intention
de se mettre à dos le secteur privé au
contraire il en a besoin pour financer
son ses réformes et c'est c'est
d'avancées sociales
deux dernières questions la question des
autochtones
effectivement c'est une question très
importante
effectivement il y a maintenant une
ministre des autochtones de même qu'il y
a une mise droit des femmes qui
n'avaient pas dans le gouvernement
précédent
le gouvernement de Monsieur Loula a fait
un geste très important il y a quelques
semaines lorsqu'il est allé rencontrer
les populations yanomaniques qui comme
vous le savez souffrent d'une
d'un appauvrissement de la région en
région de l'orpaillage et de la
déforestation puisque ils sont privés de
ressources d'eau potable et de culture
de surface cultivable
donc je sais que le président Lola aura
à cœur de mettre en avant la défense de
ces populations et également à travers
l'Amazonie la défense de leur de leur
mode de vie traditionnelle tout en les
engageant à avoir des modes de vie
respectueux de l'environnement donc ce
sera une un volant important de son
action mais qu'il essaiera bien sûr de
d'orienter vers une un développement
durable
enfin concernant le conflit en Ukraine
monsieur le sénateur en fait le Brésil
ne s'abstient pas aux Nations Unies il
l'a fait une seule fois au Conseil de
sécurité
sur les questions de d'adhésion
d'annexion de territoire
Ukrainiens mais il sait sinon toujours
prononcé en faveur des résolutions de
l'Assemblée Générale récemment
d'ailleurs la résolution du 23 février
qui a marqué l'anniversaire de
l'adhésion pardon de l'annexion russe en
Ukraine
je pense que sa position qu'il cherche
équilibrée est dû à des raisons
politiques le Brésil souhaite s'imposer
comme une grande nation libre de ses
choix et nous savons que comme membres
des briques voilà il cherchera à avoir
une certaine distance vis-à-vis de ce
conflit mais également pour les raisons
économiques de dépendance aux engrais et
nous sommes en train d'étudier
d'ailleurs la manière dont l'Union
européenne pourrait constituer
une une source d'approvisionnement
alternatif il est compliqué au Brésilien
de
produire eux-mêmes des engrais parce
qu'ils n'ont pas nécessairement toutes
les technologies pour le faire mais en
revanche je pense que nous pourrions
essayer de diminuer sa dépendance en
proposant des solutions européennes
j'espère avoir tout couvert
j'ai
Bruno
dame la directrice
la question n'a pas été posée donc je me
permets de venir par derrière sur le
Mercosur
c'est une négociation très importante
menée par
par Bruxelles directement normalement
les États n'ont pas
à savoir ce qui se passe où en sont des
négociations et pour autant
la France a des conditions je crois
savoir que Bruxelles voudrait terminer
cette négociation le plus tôt possible
et la France exige des clauses miroir
par exemple on interdit les OGM en
France mais par contre on en importe du
Brésil etc etc on pourrait multiplier
les exemples les usage d'herbicides
d'insecticides etc et par conséquent ma
question est toute simple est-ce que
vous pensez que cette négociation va
aboutir
ce qui fera que finalement en matière
agricole par exemple on va continuer à
importer ce qu'on interdit de produire
chez nous merci
oui madame une question complémentaire
sur une une interrogation quand même
importante pour nous tous c'est par
rapport à l'Amazonie on a un petit peu
évoqué mais il se trouve que la
politique de déforestation les enjeux
que nous avons en matière de transition
donc
verte et notamment le pacte vert au
niveau européen
qui est tourne en train de négocier de
mettre donc sur les rails par rapport à
cela parce que c'est tenu un véritable
cataclysme qui s'est passé sous la
période de la présidentielle sous-marro
par rapport justement au poumon vert de
l'Amazonie qui déstabilise complètement
donc l'équilibre mondial en matière donc
de poumons verts et d'ozone
donc vous connaissez là la position de
la France
l'accord ne doit pas conduire à une
augmentation de la déforestation
importée en Europe et plus généralement
les politiques publiques des pays du
Mercosur doivent être conformes à leurs
engagements au titre de l'accord de
Paris et de la corde association cet
accord d'association a été finalisé la
négociation était finalisée en 2019 nous
sommes maintenant dans une phase de
nouveaux accords des accords mixtes qui
supposent d'avoir des engagements
commerciaux dans la partie commerciale
mais également des engagements sur
d'autres terrains et ce que la France a
indiqué comme condition pour se rallier
à l'accord c'est que l'accord respecte
engage ces participants à respecter
l'accord de Paris qui ne se traduisent
pas par davantage de déforestation
importée et qu'il que les produits
importés respectent les mêmes normes
sanitaires et phytosanitaires que les
produits produits en Europe ou en
sommes-nous de cet accord alors c'est
vrai que l'élection du président lola a
relancé la dynamique puisque son à son
arrivée il a souhaité que la négociation
soit relancée pour une conclusion
le plus tôt possible
la Commission européenne donc est en
train de de rédiger un projet
d'instrument additionnel de l'accord
Mercosur pour introduire des clauses
complémentaires et
juridiquement contraignantes qui
viendrait compléter l'accord sur les
domaines où il ne l'est pas dans sa
concerne effectivement l'environnement
mais également question sociale de droit
du travail
donc c'est la Commission européenne qui
a le sujet entre les mains elle négocie
avec les deux blocs donc nous n'avons
pas vu l'accord additionnel mais elle
consulte les deux blocs Union européenne
pays du Mercosur sur cet instrument nous
ne savons pas quand les travaux vont
aboutir mais le président de la
République évidemment indiqué que nous
ne pourrions nous prononcer que au vu de
l'instrument additionnel
bon nous pensons si vous voulez je n'ai
pas vraiment de calendrier à vous
indiquer une signature durant le sommeil
yoc c'est pas possible c'est dans trois
mois donc tout le monde est bien
conscient que ce n'est pas possible
il faut pas oublier quand même que dans
les blocs il y a différentes
appréciations ce n'est pas la France qui
bloque l'aquarium Mercosur en Europe les
Autrichiens les Allemands les Pays-Bas
ont des exigences du côté latine
américain les Argentins on redit que il
fallait que l'accord ne soit pas pour
eux une source de comment dire de
déséquilibre économique le Brésil étudie
l'accord mais n'a pas encore de position
consolidée sur le texte de l'accord qui
est un accord très volumineux les pays
les plus allonges je dirais c'est
l'Uruguay et le Paraguay surtout le
ruguay qui est un pays d'exportation
agricole très importante donc voyez il y
a deux blocs qui ont des positions
différenciées la commission qui
travaille à un instrument additionnel je
ne sais pas quand ça peut aboutir les
travaux sont en cours mais en tout cas
nous nous serons vigilants sur ce sur le
respect des normes environnementales et
justement je fais le lien avec la
question de madame la sénatrice sur
l'Amazonie bon nous nous pouvons agir
alors effectivement la déforestation de
l'Amazonie a été augmenté de 70% durant
le dernier mandat présidentiel donc
c'est une priorité absolue pour le
président Lola que de stopper cette
déforestation la simple comment dire
arrêt de la déforestation suffirait pour
le Brésil à remplir ses obligations en
termes de contrôle des émissions effet
de serre
donc l'Union européenne peut agir avoir
plusieurs voix par ces programmes de
coopération nous-mêmes à avec l'AFD nous
nous essayons d'avoir des projets qui
facilitent
favorisent la lutte contre la
déforestation mais l'aquarium mercosour
lui-même est un instrument puisque à
travers le respect des accords de Paris
nous
obtiendrons le respect
par le Brésil de normes d'objectifs qui
contribueront à la lutte contre la
derforestation nous savons que le Brésil
les fondamental pour la lutte contre le
changement global vu sa superficie c'est
c'est 40% d'Amazonie 40% du territoire
même plus de l'Amérique latine
l'Amazonie n'est pas que brésilienne
elle est avant tout brésilienne et la
souveraineté brésilienne est importante
mais elle est également vénézuélienne
colombienne péruvienne bolivienne et
puis bien sûr l'aiguillane dont la nôtre
sont amazoniens donc si vous voulez il y
a aussi un ensemble de pays qui doivent
s'entendre et ce n'est pas forcément
facile d'arriver avec les consensus sur
des sujets si sensibles voilà ce que je
peux vous dire
un module
donc j'ai compris que vous allez vous
rendre également à George Town monsieur
le Président enfin votre commission se
rendre à George Town
donc
le Guyana c'est un ancien pays pauvre et
un futur pays riche un pays très riche
nous assistons à une transformation
économique majeure grâce à la mise en
exploitation de champ de pétrole au sort
qui ont été découvert récemment je vais
vous donner quelques chiffres pour
illustrer ce baume économique je
rappellerai quand même que le pays c'est
215000 km² donc à peu près la moitié de
la France un peu moins de la moitié
c'est 800 000 habitants donc c'est une
petite population sur un grand
territoire
le Guyana disposerait de près de 11
milliards de barils de pétrole au large
de ces côtes pour donc pour une
population de 800 000 habitants
et il se classe au second rang mondial
pour le rapport entre la population et
le volume des réserves estimé des droits
d'hydrocarbures et donc le
bouleversement auquel on peut s'attendre
grâce à l'exploitation et l'afflux de
revenus pétroliers et donc d'une ampleur
majeure
effectivement depuis 2020 le pays
enregistre la plus forte croissance
mondiale puisque malgré la pandémie de
covid-19 le Guyana enregistré 43% de
croissance de son PIB en 2020 donc
qu'est-ce que ça aurait été sans la
pandémie 20 % en 2021 100% en 2022 et on
estime qu'entre 2023 et 2026 l'économie
devrait croître de 25% alors bien sûr
c'est c'est ces ressources pourraient
permettre en développement très rapide
du pays qui dispose déjà de marge
budgétaires très confortables
le pays produit actuellement 350
000 barils par jour et sa production
d'ici 2027 pourrait augmenter à un
million de barils par jour
ce qu'on voit c'est que parfois le la
gestion de ressources aussi abondante
n'est pas facile parce que ce beau ne
pétrolier arrive dans un pays assez
démuni ou la vie politique est marquée
par un fort bipartisme entre le Parti
progressiste du peuple du président
actuel irfanali qui représente
majoritairement la population
indo-ruyanienne vous savez qu'il y a
deux communautés au Guyana la population
indigo guyanienne qui qui appelait lead
qui domine le pays et la coalition apnu
a fait AFD qui est l'alliance des pays
afro Guyaniens qui est actuellement dans
l'opposition alors il y a eu une
contentieux électoral lors des dernières
élections régionales
qui ont confirmé ce clivage le président
actuel
le président enfin le président actuel
donc le président sortant le qui était
de la majorité de la de la communauté
afro guyanais a perdu de peu les
élections à remis en cause les résultats
et cette situation a plongé le Guyana
dans une crise profonde pendant
plusieurs mois qu'il a privé de
gouvernement et de Parlement parce que
la défaite ou la victoire était de
courte
dimension et finalement c'est la Cour
internationale de Justice de la CARICOM
qui a tranché la crise et puis la
pression internationale qui ont permis
la déclaration de victoire de
l'opposition donc le président sortant
admise à défaite et a laissé la place
sans violence au président Irfan Ali qui
représente donc la
communauté Indo guyanienne le principal
défi pour le Guyana ça va être la
gestion inclusive de ces ressources
pétrolières de cette manne pétrolière
dont la communauté afro guyanienne
craint d'être privé
et donc l'enjeu majeur c'est le pilotage
d'un processus de développement
équilibré au plan économique social et
environnemental qui permettent une bonne
gestion de l'entrée massive de ces
recettes et pour cela le gouvernement a
mis en place un fond un fond de
ressources naturelles qui la placée
auprès d'une institution financière
new-yorkaise afin que ces ressources ne
soient pas par exemple objet de
corruption ou de mauvais usage
donc parfois l'abondance est difficile à
gérer je pense que il vous en parleront
sur le plan international évidemment le
Guyana est devenu un partenaire de plus
en plus convoité dans le contexte de son
boom pétrolier
le Premier ministre indien c'est
d'ailleurs rendu au Guyane en 2018 le
secrétaire d'État américain en 2019 gère
et borsonro en 2022 et le ministre du
pétrole saoudien en février 2022
pour l'instant c'est l'Américain exon
mobile qui est l'acteur petrolier
principal au Guyana qui n'a pas de
compagnie nationale
et puis alors les relations du guéana
avec les États-Unis et le Canada sont
facilités par l'existence de fortes
communautés guyanienne dans ces deux
pays
vous entendrez lorsque vous irez Guana
une demande du gna de renforcer ses
relations avec la France je dois dire
que nous sommes le seul État à avoir une
présence diplomatique
à George Town aucun autre membre de
l'Union européenne ne dispose
d'ambassades ou seul une délégation de
l'Union européenne est présente
actuellement nous avons un agent qui est
donc détaché de ce qui est rallié si
vous voulez la représentation
diplomatique est assurée par notre
ambassade ou Suriname par un arrêt par
maravibo l'ambassadeur apparemment Hibo
est en compétent pour le Guyana
également
nous avons un agent un agent qui est un
volontaire international qui est placé
physiquement auprès dans les locaux de
la délégation de l'Union européenne
et qui met en oeuvre des actions de
coopération nous avons récemment adopté
un fond de solidarité pour les projets
innovants dotés de plus de 500000 euros
qui vise à protéger les forêts donc vous
voyez à nouveau par la coopération
bilatérale nous luttons contre la
déforestation
en protégeant les forêts en élargissant
les droits fonciers des peuples
autochtones et en soutenant l'accès à
leurs moyens de subsistance et leur
droit à la prise de décision
nous savons que cette représentation
n'est pas suffisante et c'est pourquoi
nous avons pris une décision il y a
quelques semaines de réhausser le statut
de notre représentation diplomatique au
Guyana en ouvrant une antenne
diplomatique c'est-à-dire en ayant un
diplomate expatrié qui sera basé à
georgstar mais qui dépendra bien sûr de
l'ambassade apparemment
donc il s'agissera de pour nous serons
le premier État membre de l'Union
européenne à disposer d'une
représentation diplomatique permanente
dans ce pays donc c'est une conscients
de l'essor qui est attendu dans ce pays
et d'une perspective pour nos
entreprises parce que nos entreprises je
parle pas forcément total mais également
des entreprises dans le domaine des
infrastructures seront intéressés
puisque
le gainage souhaite protéger ses
installations pétrolières en mer ce qui
ouvre des espaces à nos entreprises du
secteur de la défense les patrouilleurs
d'océan les hélicoptères d'Airbus les
matériels de surveillance côtière de
Thalès les drones de surveill ance de
safran
il y aura donc une délégation
d'entreprise
qui sera envoyé par la Chambre de
commerce de Guyane pour prospecter le
marché Guyana en mai donc du 14 au 17
mai non après votre visite une
délégation d'entreprise pour voir les
opportunités pour nos entreprises et
puis nous avons aussi souhaité dans le
cas d'une approche stratégique lancée
une approche commune des menaces et donc
en 2021 nous avons lancé le dialogue
stratégique du plateau d'aiguillages qui
comprend des représentants du Guyana du
Suriname de France et de Brésil en
observateur qui est organisé par les
forces armées françaises en Guyane
donc cette la première édition a eu lieu
en 2021
la seconde en 2022 et la troisième
édition devrait être reçue par le Guyana
donc nous avons conscience de des enjeux
qui qui affectent le plateau
d'aiguillian et de la nécessité d'avoir
une approche commune des menaces voilà
ce que je voulais vous dire donc vous
allez arriver dans un pays en profonde
transformation
j'ajoute quand même que la Chine
évidemment n'a pas
c'est pas passé
comment dire après conscience du fort
potentiel du Guyana et elle renforce les
entreprises chinoises renforcent leur
présence en particulier dans le domaine
de la construction des infrastructures
des contacts politiques ont été établis
au plus haut niveau
le ministre des Affaires étrangères
chinois s'est rendu au Guyana et en 2021
le président guyanien et ses ministres
ont tenu une réunion virtuelle avec le
président chez inping et j'ajoute que le
Guyana adhéré aux routes de la soie donc
la tshana National airfoste Corporation
détient une participation directe de 25%
dans un bloc de d'exploitation de
pétrole offshore donc là aussi face à la
présence américaine on a la montée d'une
présence chinoise avec la recherche de
ressources naturelles
voilà mais si vous avez des questions je
serai heureuse
je n'envoie ah alors c'est folio
il y avait des ressources de pétrole
dans notre zone économique exclusive en
Guyane et puis nous avons pris une
délibération
unilatérale de ne pas aller jusqu'au
bout par rapport à l'argument que que
l'on s'empoing chez certaines de dire
que ça aurait pu être un levier de
développement pour pour la Guyane
comment dire dans le droit fil de ce qui
se passe au Guyana quels arguments
pensez-vous que l'on peut mettre en
avant par rapport à cela
je ne sais pas répondre à votre question
le Guyana est bon souverain pour décider
de l'exploitation de ses ressources j'ai
pas vraiment bien compris votre question
monsieur sénateur ma question c'est dire
que les ressources pétrolières qui a
sous le Guyana
nous savons que dans la zone économique
exclusive de la Guyane française il y a
aussi des ressources de pétrole
et que par rapport par rapport à cela un
moment donné on n'est pas allé jusqu'au
bout des des travaux de prospection et
de et de recherche de ce pétrole et que
certains en Guyane disent après tout
nous nous aurions pu avoir un levier de
développement pour notre notre
département au travers de l'exploitation
de ces ressources regarde ce qui se
passe au Guyana voilà
je vous fais réagir sur son
effectivement c'est une décision qui a
été prise au niveau national qui qui
sort un peu du cadre diplomatique mais
un peu difficile de répondre à votre
question au nom de je suis que le
ministère des Affaires étrangères je ne
suis pas le ministère des hommes des de
l'outre-mer voilà mais c'est vrai que
c'est une aubaine pour le Guyana qui
était un pays extrêmement pauvre donc
c'est des situations différentes
au départ après effectivement il faudra
que Louisiana trouve des ressources
comment dire conforme aux attentes de
l'accord de Paris qui est des
transitions écologiques et énergétiques
on est tous à la recherche de d'énergie
des carbonée évidemment bien sûr ça
tombe un peu tard bien sûr mais
Rachid bon anniversaire Rachid merci
un demi siècle ça se voit pas non non
plus ce que vous dites sur Ghana et le
pétrole mais c'est toujours facile quand
les de le dire quand on est d'ici et de
la partie plutôt industrialisée donc si
on ne veut pas que des gens utilisent
des
énergies fossiles encore faut-il qu'ils
aient moins autrement et donc la
question qui est donnée c'est comment il
se développe dans ce cas là sinon c'est
très sympa de dire deux siècles après
avoir fait nous l'époque dans tout cela
et puis dire aux autres maintenant vous
n'avez pas le droit de vous développer
donc oui voilà l'accord de Paris oui un
économie des carbonisée des carbonée
mais encore faut-il dire ce qu'on fait à
la place parce que sinon c'est sympa
mais c'est pas possible
merci de cette prise de position
pas d'autres interventions Madame la
Directrice merci infiniment bien
évidemment le suite à la visite
importante qui va être
effectué au Brésil au Guyana il y aura
un rapport de la commission enfin de la
délégation et j'espère que
nous pourrons ainsi enrichir la
réflexion du du ministère et du
gouvernement mais en tous les cas le
sentiment moi que je voulais vous
transmettre aujourd'hui parce que
j'ai déjeuné avec les 15 ambassadeurs là
d'Amérique latine c'est qu'effectivement
il faut que l'on monte bien sûr
vis-à-vis du Brésil mais vis-à-vis de
tous les autres y compris les plus
petits
beaucoup d'attention parce que ils ont
ce sentiment alors vous et à juste titre
vous avez résumé les nombreuses visites
les accueils par le Président de la
République mais je fais part quand même
de ce sentiment parce que chaque fois
j'entends la même chose donc je sais
Monsieur le Président et je m'emploie à
corriger la tendance et à proposer
à ses partenaires à dire américains des
occasions de rencontres des opportunités
nous serons évidemment preneurs de
rapport de de la du placement nous
aurons par l'ambassade d'un rapport de
votre mission qui sera extrêmement utile
puisqu'il interviendra juste avant les
consultations politiques et puis je
voulais signaler puisque le Sénat est à
l'origine que la nous organiserons les
semaines de l'Amérique latine du 25 mai
au 10 juin au départ c'est le Sénat qui
a eu l'idée de créer une journée de
l'Amérique latine en 2011 qui est devenu
une semaine qui est devenue une
quinzaine et dont nous avons réuni hier
les ambassadeurs latines américains pour
leur donner les les échéances et c'est
aussi une occasion de mettre en valeur
nos liens culturels scientifiques
économiques politiques donc nous faisons
beaucoup pour essayer de corriger cette
tendance et et réellement nous avons
intérêt à développer avec ces pays des
relations stratégiques économiques
politiques culturelles sachez que mon
équipe et moi-même nous ayons très bien
c'est que c'est saoule sous l'impulsion
personnelle du président du Sénat qui a
des relations familiale avec un des pays
du nord de l'Amérique latine mais
effectivement il y a chaque année
un accueil des ambassadeurs avec des
remises de prix
des scientifiques et c'est effectivement
attendu merci infiniment Madame la
Directrice
merci beaucoup
quelques